what is up everybody its Anna Mike here
for anime uproar and today I will be
once again diving deep into the twisted
world of attack on Titan and I will be
breaking down all the latest
developments in the story we now have a
much better idea of what Aaron is really
up to if what he just told us is really
the truth and we've also received some
very valuable information about the past
about Aaron's State of Mind and
international relations in the attack on
Titan world at this point making these
videos and then talking with you guys in
the comments about them is the only way
I can truly come to terms with this
powerful but also difficult story so
basically making these videos and then
discussing them with you guys is the
best way for me to organize all the
attack on Titan thoughts that swirl
around in my head with the release of
every new installment to the story if
you enjoyed these videos do you want me
to keep it going please leave a like to
let me know and if you happen to be new
to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications if you
don't turn on all notifications you will
probably miss a lot of our videos that's
just the way it goes so please if you
like the videos turn on all
notifications there will of course be
spoilers in this video we're talking
about the latest developments in the
attack on Titan stories so please
proceed with caution you have been
warned I mentioned in the previous video
that I just cannot rush these video
analyses of the attack on Titan chapters
because not only are the chapters
themselves long but there is always so
much to understand so much to dissect
and so much to talk about that I
honestly feel like I wouldn't be able to
do a good enough job if I tried to rush
it
I actually considered trying to get a
video out ASAP this time around because
I know a lot of you would enjoy to watch
it right away but I realized that if I
did that the quality of this video would
suffer so I decided to give it time I
really appreciate all of you who do wait
and watch the videos once they come out
thank you so much
chapter one two three begins with an
important flashback at some point during
the four year time skips so sometime
after the scouts reached the ocean but
before Aaron infiltrated Marlay as a
wounded veteran a large delegation of
scouts traveled to Marlay in disguise
in order to explore and try to
understand the outside world they travel
to the continent aboard a steamship and
dressed in marlane clothing so that they
wouldn't stand out in such a hostile
environment it was very important for
them to keep their identities and true
origins a secret the flashback is being
told through the perspective of Mikasa
finally some focus on Mikasa I feel like
it's been so long since we've gone to
explore her perspective a bit more you
guys who have been watching this channel
for awhile know that I love Micasa
and I ship her with Aaron and this
chapter was quite an emotional roller
coaster for me to say the least
anyway through the flashback we get to
witness the very first time that the
scouts encountered Marley and the
outside world in general and better yet
we get to see more of Levi and our
precious potato girl Sasha which itself
makes the whole chapter worthwhile in my
opinion if anyone was Micah's rival for
best girl in my heart it was definitely
Sasha and I just know shut up I'm not
gonna cry moving on moving on as the
scouts disembark from the steamship and
step foot on the continent for the first
time they experience quite a culture
shock
they are unfamiliar with the way that
Marlin society works and they have never
seen modern technology like automobiles
in their entire lives
this makes them appear as completely
clueless country bumpkins and while some
Scouts are good at concealing that they
don't belong here
others like Sasha Kony and hanji are
pretty bad at it since they basically
attempt to feed carrots to a car
thinking it's a cow or horse they better
hope that country bumpkins is all that
the Marlins are going to mistake them
for because if anyone figured out the
truth it would be a lot worse inside the
city they're met by a Yank on poun who
you will recall is a non marlane whose
country was forcibly taken over by
Marlay he was then forcibly conscripted
into the Marlon Army but he is now
secretly working against male and we
have seen him before in the present time
as one of the volunteers who decided to
fight against male on parodies he leads
the scouts to the azuma BTO residence
and it is clear that some important
meeting is supposed to occur there I
mean why else would they risk bringing
so many island
all the way here to the continent inside
the enemy's lair and gathering them all
there in one place at the same time it
is a very very dangerous act Sasha and
Kony continue to stand out by showing
the wildermann tat discovering ice cream
for the first time and Levi expresses
concern that they are drawing too much
attention to themselves but overall
Sasha and Kony just seems so childish
and ignorant that it is unlikely that
anyone would perceive them as any sort
of threat let alone suspect them of
being those evil Devils from the island
of parodies however one thing I didn't
mention is I've been talking to you
about these events is that throughout
the chapter it is clearly implied that
something is off about Aaron something
is different about Aaron he is
absent-minded and quiet and he is
nowhere near as excited as Armin and
Micah's I would have expected him to be
after all Aaron always dreamed of seeing
the outside world of journeying beyond
the walls and beyond the ocean and
discovering all the incredible things
that the world has to offer but now that
he is actually here Aaron seems
extremely passive and apathetic he seems
almost sad this could be because he is
seeing the memories that his father has
of Marley or because he is seeing future
memories or some combination of the two
at that point a refugee child from yet
another nation that was attacked and
taken over by male attempts to take
Sasha's wallet Levi stops him from
making off with the wallet but this
attracts a lot of unwanted attention
from the Marlins in the crowd the crowd
is immediately vicious towards the child
calling for severe punishment and even
execution in order to set an example for
the other immigrants and refugees Sasha
and the scouts tried to calm the
situation down saying that her wallet is
fine and the child doesn't need to be
punished but the Marlins then begin to
talk about the fact that other countries
have been conducting experiments with LD
and blood and this child might even have
blood from the devil's mixed in
therefore the child must be done away
with because he might pose a danger to
the native Marlins this scene is short
but very important in my opinion because
it shows the mentality and the culture
of the Marlins first of all these are
not Marlins soldiers these are normal
everyday
on the streets and they're not just
racist and hateful towards the ldiots
they're also racist and hateful towards
other nations and races including the
immigrants and refugees from the
countries that they themselves conquered
by force Marlay is literally responsible
for why these people are refugees marley
brought war and destruction to their
countries and still they show no
sympathy or empathy for these people
their first instinct is to attack and
eliminate everyone who is different from
them and they always seem to use the LD
ins and LD in blood as some sort of
ever-present boogeyman that justifies
all of their terrible actions I'm not
going to make a direct historical
comparison because of YouTube censorship
of any even slightly controversial topic
but I'm sure you can pick up on that
historical comparison as well
Levi feels bad for the refugee child
then he picks him up and walks away with
him the crowd of Marlins asks what is he
doing but he tries to make the argument
that Sasha is actually the kids sister
and all of this was just some sibling
teasing not a real case of pickpocketing
the angry Marlins aren't buying it but
Levi and the scouts succeed and running
away from the crowd and saving the child
from their hateful grasp the scouts
allow the child to escape with the
wallet nonetheless and then they all
make their way to the azuma beto
residence Kiyomi azuma Beto explains
that due to advancements in technology
it has now become possible to conduct
blood tests in order to determine who is
descendant from aliens and therefore a
subject of Amir back when the alien
Empire was at its peak having the blood
of the subjects of Amir was a valuable
asset and proof of nobility however
after the fall of the Empire those with
LDN blood were persecuted and banished
from other nations and to this day the
reality faced by audience is harsh and
cruel as a result establishing alliances
with other nations will be extremely
difficult for the people of Paradise
Island everyone fears and distrust the
LD ins because of the legacy of the LDN
Empire and because of their ability to
turn into Titans but the scouts are
still hopeful that they can find some
peaceful solution a solution that avoids
Zeke's plan and an all-out war against
Marlay and the other
patience they want to promote the
interests of the subjects of Emir and
they want to promote the cause of peace
at the International Forum which is
taking place the next day I assume that
this is some sort of conference that
involves representatives from various
different countries discussing ways to
prevent war and promote peace and
economic prosperity kind of like the
international forums and summits that we
have in our own world
hanji and the others plan to reach out
to an association that is trying to
protect the rights of the subjects of
Emir and tell them that the LD ends on
paradise also want peace Kiyomi warns
them that this is going to be extremely
difficult to do but as hanji points out
they simply have to try their best at
this point the scouts noticed that Aaron
isn't there anymore and Micah's
eventually finds him at a refugee camp a
makeshift settlement made of tents where
the young pickpocket boy and his family
are living Micah's asks Aaron why he
would go out on his own when he knows
that he is the enemy's prime target
but Aaron isn't very talkative when
Mikasa asks him whether something
happened Aaron says nothing yet as if he
knows something is about to happen in
the future this could be Aaron's future
memories giving him clues about what
will happen years from now and perhaps
Aaron saw that this refugee camp would
be destroyed at some point in the future
perhaps it will even be destroyed as a
result of the actions that Aaron is
about to take in the present time Aaron
mentions that this camp is where those
who lost their homes because of the war
are now forced to live aaron compares
this to their own situation back on
parody's they also lost their homes and
became refugees because of the war and
more specifically because of the
shifters sent by Marlay to destroy wall
maria as aaron observes one day their
everyday lives suddenly ended and
everything was stolen from them all
their freedom was stolen from them their
childhood was stolen from them it is
almost a reference to fate it is as if
the attack on wall maria set events in
motion that cannot be stopped the ironic
thing about Aaron's character at this
point in the story is that he wants
freedom more than anything else but he
also knows what is going to happen in
the
so is Aaron truly free can he ever be
truly free or are his actions and
choices already predestined does knowing
the future actually rob Aaron of the
freedom to choose or is it perhaps
possible to change the future depending
on what choices Aaron decides to make
this idea of freedom versus
predestination is likely going to play a
more important role as the story
continues we know what grisha's said to
Zeke that Aaron is going to do something
horrible and unspeakable something
beyond anything that he had even
imagined so is there an destined to do
this or can he choose to take a
different path and if he is not free to
choose then is he free at all even if he
succeeded in destroying all of his
enemies at once
would he be free even then if his entire
future is already set out for him Aaron
then asks Myka saw a very direct
question he asks her why she concerns
herself so much with him is it because
she was saved by him as a child is it
because they're family then he suddenly
asks what am I to you because it looks
confused and flushed she is clearly
blushing but she simply answers you are
family
she literally families owns him then the
other Scouts show up also concerned
about Aaron and what's he been up to and
then all of them are invited into one of
the tents by the refugees the refugees
generously offer food and drinks to the
scouts and they all sit together and
break bread eventually they start
drinking alcohol and they party and get
drunk until they pretty much pass out
hanji Levi and Owen can pond find them
all sleeping in the tent later on that
night and Levi's face pretty much says
it all about what he thinks about this
whole situation the following day at the
International Forum in front of a large
crowd are representatives of the people
who are fighting for the rights of the
subjects of Emir calls for sympathy and
compassion for those in Marlay with LD
and blood but then he goes on to say
that the LD ends on the continent are
just victims of the LDN empires
crossbreeding and that the ones who
should have been despised from the
beginning are those Devils from
Paradise Island the man calls those
ldiots who went to the island 100 years
ago the true enemies and the ones who
should be detested and several people
appear to clap and cheer as the scouts
look on in shock
clearly there was no intention of ever
making peace with the island of paradise
the LD ends on the island are constantly
just being used as scapegoats and as an
outlet for all the hatred that the world
feels for the audience on the continent
this organization that allegedly fights
for the rights of the subject of aamir
is apparently fighting for the rights of
the audience on the continent by
scapegoating and demonizing the other
aliens on the island as the real devils
and the real threat at this point
Aaron calmly gets out and leaves the
forum and since that day he stopped
going along with the peacemaking
strategy of the scouts instead he wrote
a letter saying that he would entrust
everything to Zeke and after that the
next time they saw each other was during
the attack on Lee berry Oh Mikasa
wonders if there was ever any other
choice or if everything was just decided
from the start again we see the conflict
of freedom versus predestination if the
future is laid out for us ahead of time
then can we ever be truly free and if we
do make different choices can we create
a different future because I can't help
but think what would have happened if
back when Aaron asked her what she is to
him she chose a different path and said
something else something other than just
family perhaps things would have turned
out differently and you can't blame me
because of her thinking this you can
never underestimate the power of an
anime waifu and the influence she has on
her anime husband though as Mikasa is
thinking all of this we see the colossal
wall Titans walking away from the scouts
and we see eren's Titan looking
completely different than it used to be
it looks like some gigantic dinosaur
Titan absolutely dwarfing in size even
the colossal Titans it also has sharper
bones poking out of its back just like
Amir's original Titan which seems to be
a clear indication that the founding
Titan Power Amir's power is now active
within eren's Titan transformation the
colossal Titans march in the direction
of Aaron's gigantic Titan and then
suddenly Armin realizes that Aaron has
taken control
all of the founding Titan and that he is
going to try and destroy the Allied
forces that are gathering in Marlay and
planning to attack parodies clearly
Zeke's plan failed because initiating
the rumbling was never part of Zeke's
plan
Aaron must have turned against Zeke in
the end Mekas an armin are surprised to
learn that Aaron is indeed on their side
and of course they are happy that he
didn't follow Zeke but then Arman
realizes something and this is actually
something that I addressed directly in
my previous attack on Titan video about
what will Aaron do next
Arman realizes that releasing all of the
colossal Titans is clearly overkill if
Aaron's goal is just to destroy the
Allied forces gathering in Marlay he
could have only released a small portion
of the Titans if he wanted simply to
defend the island from one invading army
what Aaron is doing indicates that he is
planning something much grander than
just winning one military battle and
then all of the subjects of Amir at the
same time hear the same voice it is
Aaron's voice and Mekas appears to be
hearing it as well
even though she is an acraman which is
in itself very interesting this means
that if Levi is alive which I believe he
is he will be hearing this message as
well Aaron explains that he is using the
founding Titan power to address all the
subjects of Amir at the same time and he
declares that the walls have been
destroyed and that all of the wall
Titans have started marching Aaron says
that his objective is to protect the
place where he was born and raised
Paradise Island and all the people on
the island but Aaron outlines the same
thing that the flashback that we saw in
this chapter demonstrates the fact is
that the world wants to annihilate the
people of paradise the hatred against
them has been built up for centuries and
they will not stop their hatred and
their attacks until every subject of
aamir on the island and off it is
destroyed Aaron refuses to accept this
instead he vows to have the Titans
trample the whole earth destroying
everything in the entire world and all
life existing there except for Paradise
Island we also see that Aaron's new
Titan transformation has a very
different look from the old one and his
face is completely diff
as well I am already working on a video
about the potential power and abilities
of Aaron's new Titan form so definitely
stick around here at anime out Pro and
be sure to look out for that but in the
meantime let's talk about the
implications of what just happened and
about Aaron's current state of mind and
his true motivations if we take Aaron
and his word and assume that he really
does plan to destroy the entire world in
order to protect parodies this makes
Aaron look like a monster willing to
kill millions and millions of people but
we have to consider this in terms of
radical self-defense what I mean by this
is that Aaron is primarily interested in
self-defense and defending his people in
his homeland from imminent attack from
Aaron's perspective he was forced out of
his home he lost his mother before his
very eyes and he had his whole life
destroyed by Marlins who launched the
mission to infiltrate wall Maria in the
first place at a very young and
impressionable age Aaron lost his mother
eventually his father his home his
freedom and over the course of his life
he would lose many more friends and
comrades all because of the Marlins even
though he himself did nothing wrong
I've mentioned this in previous videos
and I apologize if I sound repetitive to
those of you who have been following the
channel for a while but I myself was a
refugee during the civil war in the
former Yugoslavia when I was a child
just about 2 or 3 years old my family
and I were refugees after war broke out
in one part of the country we moved to
another part of the country but then war
broke out there too and so we were
refugees again losing our homes and
everything else in the process we also
lost friends and even some more distant
family members in the war and we
eventually emigrated to Canada which is
of course a first world country but
because of my childhood experiences as a
refugee I can definitely understand
where Aaron is coming from Aaron didn't
start any war the war came to him and he
lost everything because of it through no
fault of his own after spending his
whole life trying to do the right thing
sacrificing his life to protect innocent
people from the Titans and trying to
make the world a better place he
realizes that the enemies who did all of
this to him in the first place have no
interest in peace they intend to
you attacking parodies in the future
until every single person on the island
is dead when Aaron and the scouts tried
to show the people on the continent that
they wanted peace that they wanted to
negotiate a peaceful solution
they were vilified yet again and all
they heard was further calls for their
destruction and annihilation even though
I think killing millions of innocent
people isn't the right decision since it
just makes you as bad as the people who
ruined your life I can't imagine how
Aaron must be feeling under these
circumstances he appears to have only
two choices either just lie down and let
the same enemies who ruin your life kill
you and everyone else you care about
along with the entire population of your
homeland or you killed the enemy before
he has a chance to kill you in my video
about the ruthless philosophy of Eren
Jaeger I did a deep dive into Aaron's
philosophy and I compared it to the
ideas of 16th century Italian
philosopher Niccolo Machiavelli I won't
get into too much of that again if you
want to check that out the video link
will be in the description but in short
Aaron now finds himself in a situation
where either he does nothing and
horrible things will happen to everyone
he loves and cares about or he takes
concrete action to protect the people he
cares about but the only way to protect
them is to do horrible things to other
people the question then becomes which
is more immoral is it sitting back and
doing nothing while your entire homeland
is destroyed or doing immoral things to
others but doing it in order to protect
the ones you love if Aaron really does
plan to destroy the whole world except
for parodies he might be thinking that
he has no other way to protect the
people he cares about
and the only home he's ever known he
might be thinking hey these other guys
started it we tried to make peace and
they keep attacking us they were warned
about the rumbling by Karl Fritz and
they still keep attacking us so now
let's give them what they deserve this
would make sense in terms of the Marlay
an army but unfortunately any plan to
destroy Marlay will involve the
destruction of many innocent people
people who are non-combatants and who
have no say in what the Maryland
military does it is just so ironic that
Aaron went from the kid who wanted to
kill all the Titans in order to save
humanity to the man who now wants to use
the Titan
to destroy all of humanity except for
the people and parodies if this truly is
what Aaron plans to do and I say if
because it's not for sure yet then it is
a real Ragnarok ending it is an
apocalypse brought about by Aaron which
will annihilate the world as we know it
only paradise will remain as a sort of
Garden of Eden a place from which
humanity and civilization can start anew
after the rumbling destroys everything
else if you want to know more about the
connection between what is happening
right now with Aaron and Ragnarok from
Norse mythology check out my previous
attack on Titan video in that video I
talked about several possible scenarios
for what Aaron might be planning to do
next
including this possibility of destroying
the entire world but in that video I
also talked about other possibilities
including the lelouch scenario according
to this scenario Aaron may be lying
about his intentions to destroy the
entire world in order to build himself
up as this massive villain and a global
threat to every nation and every person
then the entire world can unite in their
hatred for Aaron and when Aaron is
finally defeated the world can live in
peace
including the ldiots but I mentioned in
that video that this would be a bit
naive
since the hatred for LD ins and
especially the audience on parodies
seems to run so deep throughout the
world I find it hard to believe that the
threat of Aaron could permanently unite
everyone and I fear that if Aaron was
defeated as soon as the threat is gone
the rest of the ldm people would again
become targets after all who says that
the next Aaron isn't hiding among the
audience the only way to stop another
Aaron from becoming a threat to the
world will be to eliminate all the LD
ends also to be honest I kind of don't
want this to be the end game of attack
on Titan because I don't want this
series to end exactly like cold Geass
Code Geass is well known for that great
ending and I want attack on Titan to do
something uniquely its own but that is
just my personal opinion finally I have
to say that all of this could be just
some form of a bluff on Aaron's part he
maybe pretending to want to destroy the
whole world while really intending to
only destroy a part of it as a warning
and then using the power of the Titans
to keep the rest of the world in
while the people and parodies catch up
to the other nations in terms of
Technology and of course once they catch
up in terms of Technology they will be
able to defend themselves from attack in
the future with or without titan powers
this is a strategy that I believe Arman
wants Eren to use and he thought that
Aaron should have released only a small
segment of the wall Titans so that they
could destroy the army which was
gathering to attack parodies and by
doing this they could send a strong
message to the rest of the world rather
than destroying the entire world after
taking all of this in I personally find
it hard to believe that Aaron would
really decide to kill everyone in the
world who is not on parodies and I think
that some type of Bluff scenario is
still likely but you never know with
Hajime isayama I also think that now
that Aaron sent a direct message to
every subject to be mirrored that he is
going to destroy the whole world
aside from parodies we are finally about
to see Annie emerge from her crystal
maybe even in the very next chapter
after all she did everything she did in
order to protect her father back in
Marlay so you better believe that she
now has no more reason whatsoever to
remain in that crystal stuck in some
cave on Paradise Island whatever happens
it's going to be absolutely epic the
next few chapters are likely going to be
the epitome of manga hype and drama and
I can't wait to see what happens next
definitely let me know what you guys
think what is going to happen next
is Annie about to make her big return
already in the next chapter and is Aaron
really going to go through with his
apocalypse plan or is he actually
planning something different after all
please give me your thoughts down in the
comments below and of course stay tuned
to anime uproar because a whole video on
Aaron's new form and its potential
powers and abilities is coming soon
right here to the channel if you enjoyed
the attack on titan content on this
channel and you want us to keep it going
please leave a like to let me know it
really does help and if you happen to be
new to anime uproar don't forget to
subscribe and hit that notification bell
to turn on all notifications you can
also hit me up on Twitter and Instagram
at anime uproar for all the latest
attack on titan news and updates i want
to give a big thank you to all of our
anime opera patrons who support us and
make
videos like this one possible special
thanks to our pro hero tier patrons
including the one and only Gilgamesh
baby ray nothing but a fan Jason Wilson
Kings L dress fitted Allah beat Anatole
Cassatt's key DJ Nathaniel and alpha do
and I can't forget are the one tier
patrons the ones who stand above all
other clans including in grata a Lola
madam madam AK makoto-kun and the world
and you know he's serious because he
didn't say so Waldo if you enjoy our
videos and you feel that they provide
value to your life please consider
becoming a patron even a single dollar
will give you access to our patron
exclusive discord and your name will
appear in our videos along with these
amazing people as always thank you guys
so much for watching and until next time
see us bass cowboys
[Music]